okay this this looks terrible the
lighting is awful I am sitting on the
floor of my parents house
I came home for Christmas and for
Christmas I got a cold I sound like a
man so it's like Greg Merry Christmas ho
ho last year I did it what I got for
Christmas video and a lot of you guys
have been requesting to see that this
year so here I am sitting on the floor
you guys are sitting on a pile of
scarves so the first give diminish show
you my mom got me this it's the world's
smartest thermometer I'm going to do a
check Tuesday on this which I probably
should open it now because let's check
my temperature this one's up to your
iPhone and it's it's an app there's a
temperature app I can't believe it new
shoes
candy the essentials I'm beast knife I
bought this for myself
candy emergency flashlight safety first
it also comes with a seatbelt cutter a
windshield breaker and some other stuff
and it'll be of shea butter mints
chapstick lint roller
toothpaste my mom knows me I need all my
travel essentials Oh new eyelash curler
my little cousin Seth got me this this
is the coolest thing ever
[Music]
so my grandma is by far the coolest and
most tech-savvy grandmother ever ever
since I started doing anything on the
Internet
she always makes these awesome books of
all of my adventures she has all of the
news things say look at that right there
breaking news look at this this is crazy
this is all of my videos and this is
this is actually only from July through
December she put it in a camo bag she
also puts everything on DVDs and she
even gave me all the magazines that I
had some appearances in does anybody
know it's in here though my sister Bree
doesn't ever play video games she
doesn't know anything about video games
but she got me some amiibo and this
little carrying case so pumped up about
it because I've been eyeing this one up
and we found it at Walmart so if you
watched the vlog you already know that
I've got Zelda
I've got Captain Falcon and Luigi and I
don't have either of these three but now
I do so I'm quite excited about it
mm well prized possession is the new
Game Stop exclusive NES Nintendo 3ds and
before you guys say just seen you just
got a Nintendo from mr. Miyamoto that is
enclosed in a plastic case that will
never be opened so I'm excited about
this I've been playing the nes remix
game it's really fun I love it I love
shopping for people for the holidays so
I got everyone on my Christmas list I
mean I got some other things as well oh
I also got myself this some emergency
focus probably thought this vlog or
maybe I didn't even post it yet but
everybody got the here we go we should
hang out sometime book from Josh
Sundquist and you guys probably have
watched his videos here on YouTube we
probably have read his first book but
his second book just came out so if you
guys don't have it already
I'll put a link in the description where
you guys can get it and if you don't
have an audible account you can go to
audible.com slash iJustine you can get a
30 day free trial of audible and may I
recommend for the hashtag IJ book club
that I get my voice back I recommend you
that we should hang out sometime a book
by Josh Sundquist he actually reads the
book to you so get to hear him read it
and you can follow along while Josh
reads it to you that's really the best
way to read well I'm gonna go because
I probably now won't be able to talk for
the rest of the day so I love you guys I
hope you guys have a really great
holiday I'm sure I'll see you tomorrow
in another video I love you have a good
day hopefully none of you guys are
getting sick hopefully you guys don't
get my sickness through the camera I am
NOT well
[Music]